session I've already got some questions
in the hopper I'm gonna put a quick
thing in the chat about my patreon
supporters thanking them for
underwriting this activity everybody
else should probably be thanking them as
well if you're not a supporter they're
the ones who help me earn a living doing
this sort of thing and they're the ones
who are underwriting and if it wasn't
for them I would not really have the
time to do it so a lot of greetings
people are giving me that's that's very
nice we got 22 people already on let's
jump to some of the questions so I had a
few minutes to look at these ahead of
time and the first question is actually
kind of a tough one for me it's who is
my favorite contemporary feminist
thinker and I don't really have a good
answer for that in part because you know
I don't really do a lot within that that
field most of the feminist thinkers that
I tend to read and teach and I was
thinking well do I have any colleagues
who I I identify dentists famine s and
whose works I I really like and I was
thinking yeah I do but most of them are
not doing it simply just as feminists
they're doing it because their interest
they didn't say ancient philosophy and
how it you know impacts modern life and
then that they're trying to think things
out like how would we take Aristotle and
read him in such a way that the the
boneheaded things he says about women
could be addressed but in an
Aristotelian perspective so I don't I
don't really have a great answer for
that I mean there's a lot of important
feminist thing who's out there but I
don't I don't really focus on a lot of
people just as feminists as such I mean
you know my favorite 20th century woman
thinkers not really contemporary she's
been dead a while it's not a rent but
you know that that's when you when
you've got our archives and you've got a
center devoted to you as they do it
College that's a sign that you've been
going for a while
alright let me jump into Heidegger stuff
so I'm gonna take the the second
question on Heidegger first and then
talk about the first one which is a
little bit more difficult Louie Louie's
Gerardo asks why do you think Heidegger
is still relevant today well because
that some of the stuff that he said is
you know you could say they're sort of
to use the lucidity czar known as sera
Titus's idea of an achievement for
eternity you know Thema AAA a possession
for eternity there's you know some
insights that he has many of which you
can find in being in time that I think
are extremely valuable the the
relationship between mood situation or
if most people like to call it you know
throne this good work League of orphan
height and for in a pre understanding
and then discourse or language Aida I
think that's a brilliant insight I think
he was wrong in assuming that anxiety is
the only you know really prime or Jolie
revelatory mood but there's other people
out there like Adrienne pepper Zack who
talk about that quite well you know his
views on the essence of technology I
think there's a lot of good stuff there
you know there's there's a you could say
there's a number of different points
where Heidegger is either relevant to
the particular situation that we're in
or the insights that he had remain
relevant to the human condition
for the foreseeable future but you could
say that about so many other
philosophers why is Aristotle relevant
today why is Gabrielle Marcel relevant
today now there's a question here about
Heidegger and being what is being in the
high daguerreian sense so in its
lowercase B in the question this is from
Nabeel so Heidegger talks about beings
right
Zion does
he talks about being sign capital case B
and then he talks about the being of
beings lowercase B lowercase B plural
and those are not the same thing right
so you might be asking about what is
being capital B in a Haida garyun sense
and you could say well in some way it's
the totality of beings but it also
includes the nothing and it includes our
own involvement in it as the kind of
being that is design that is concerned
with being and concerned with its own
being and the other thing I'll say about
this because I do want to get onto the
other questions is Heidegger thinks that
throughout the history of ideas in the
West there are a number of productive
misunderstandings of being capital B so
Plato is one of the first people to do
this and then Aristotle has a different
one and then you kind of jumps over the
Hellenistic philosopher is right into
the Christian thinkers but you could say
a similar thing for the Hellenistic
philosophers and and so on all the way
down to Nietzsche who is in heidegger's
view the last metaphysician in each case
some some kind of being lowercase B what
he calls a region of being is taken as
being determinative of the other beings
lowercase B plural and it sort of
substitutes in there for being uppercase
B being and so you know with Plato we
take the forms the the a day or you da
day I as being being right or we take
the form of forms and not the form of
forms the form of the good the form of
the beautiful as being lobbying with
Christianity that becomes God with Hegel
it becomes spirit you know Nietzsche
becomes will the power right and each of
these is something that's a productive
misunderstanding because it introduces
something
new a new way of looking at things that
is in some respects useful for some
kinds of beings but it's wrong insofar
as it is trying to take all of being and
put it in there all right let me
oh it's already quite a few things here
let me jump to the next one's a crowbar
do I agree or disagree with the notion
there's an epidemic of narcissism
spreading across the United States in
the modern digital era well so let's
clarify there are we talking about
narcissism in the clinical sense or are
we talking about it in sort of a
pop-culture sense clinical sense I don't
know that there's been a you know
greater prevalence of narcissistic
personality disorder being diagnosed but
in you know in a pop culture
loosey-goosey kind of sense maybe I
don't know that it's simply tie to the
digital era I think that it could be you
know a result of many other things and I
don't know that there's an epidemic of
it I would say people of in general are
narcissistic that that sense and it
happened long before the digital era a
lot a lot of people are kind of selfish
and self-centered and you know have
their blinders on and are primarily
concerned about how things are gonna
affect them I think that's kind of a
constant throughout most most cultures
and most most eras do we want to call
that narcissism or do we want to reserve
that term for when it becomes a bit more
pathological I don't know it so that's
that's kind of an open question I would
say I don't observe more of it in my
students in this contemporary generation
that I did in the previous generation
and I've been teaching now for 20 years
so you know I'm not seeing it myself oh
wow this is a tough one Francis Francis
always asks good questions what are the
most important intellectual skills not
often taught to new philosophers what
hard core intellectual exercises can
train
them Wow at that that's a that's a great
question that probably should you know
that could use a blog entry or a video
one is like how to handle criticism and
rejection well and I don't think that
people really spend much time on that
until rejection happens and they're like
well you don't get back on the horse and
and or they're like well I remember what
it was like but we don't we don't deal
with it in a sort of coherent way and
that that is an important that is an
important aspect of academics as well as
of so many other things romantic life
the job market now are their
intellectual exercises that could help
you with that yeah this is where like
stoicism and I think other perspectives
like Platonism and aristotelianism offer
us helpful things also existentialist
perspectives offer us helpful ways of
preparing for that and you know the
negative visualization exercises that
are important for for stoicism are a
good example of that although you know
those are not unique to stoicism there's
many Christian thinkers who who do
similar things as well and what else is
needed being able to you know a lot of
the skills are really like emotional
management skills and and emotional
management not just in the sense of like
understanding your emotions and dealing
with them but seeing how they connect up
with cognitions because there's a
tendency for philosophers to become a
little bit over intellectual and to
ignore what's going on within the
totality of their psyches myself
included you know I speak from
experience on that learning how to have
productive conversations with people who
you disagree with without coming across
as a kind of con incent condescending
sort of prick that's that's a useful
skill that's not really well taught or
modeled in philosophy departments
but that's a great question that's why
actually I think I'd like to think about
more so Frances you should email me and
remind me about that because I have a
few other things that I have to get out
this weekend in terms of writing but
that that's something I would like to do
awful philosophy
what about Adorno do you like you've
mentioned him and enjoying his thought
in the past but never with much detail
so he's not somebody who I've read
recently quite honestly and by recently
I mean like in the last couple years the
last time I was digging into him was was
just reading through the aesthetic
theory Adorno is is a very difficult
thinker to read in part because there's
so much packed in there and he's
engaging in reflection constantly and he
references so many different things I
would say Adorno is as far as like
getting a lot out of him is at the level
of toughness of Hegel what I do enjoy is
that he gives me a lot of great insights
about how things could be looked at in
different ways or how they're connected
with each other you know I mean you read
some things and you're like well
probably off base on this but you can
say the same thing about Heidegger you
could say the same thing about Aristotle
or you can say the same thing about
Hegel right
my very first no not the very first I
think I'd published one other thing
before that but my one of my very early
publications was actually on Adorno and
I consider doing my master's thesis on
him but instead I wound up doing it on
who Cyril and disel Sir Nicholas the
silentium do you have any other youth
philosophy youtubers you suggest I don't
really spend much time watching other
people's videos in part because I don't
have the time people ask me there's
about podcasts what podcasts do you
listen to well not much because I spend
so much time either reading or meeting
with clients you know in my
my work new tutorials consulting or you
know producing videos or producing sound
files or producing online classes I
don't get much time to watch other
people so I can't make any competent
recommendations and I'm - - are what is
it to understand that's one of those you
know questions sort of like Augustine
you know in in confessions what's time
so long as nobody asked me I grasp it
perfectly fine soon if somebody asked me
now I don't really know understanding
you know it depends I think I think
understanding is one of those poly semuc
or ambiguous meaning it has more than
one meaning and they're connected
together kind of terms and here's
something I'll say - it means sometimes
something different in one school or
movement of philosophy than it does in
another so for example you'll see in the
Middle Ages people making a distinction
between the intellect or understanding
the intellectus and reason rots you know
reason is discursive understanding is
more kind of holistic intuitive grasping
everything all at once and then it gets
totally reversed it with the German
idealist where understanding becomes
something you know more or less of the
concepts in this worldly and and reason
is a higher faculty so I I would say
there's different modes of understanding
you know there's understanding that
something is the case there's
understanding how to do something and
notice that this is similar to the issue
of law what is it - no there's more than
one mode of knowledge as well cyrix is
asking me about something that I don't
think can be done how do you convince an
entire humanity to sacrifice their wants
for the needs of the children of the
future well I mean you don't it's tough
enough convincing everybody that they
should eat at the same restaurant alone
that or that we should have pizza
tonight let alone that
all of humanity ought to sacrifice their
wants for the needs of the children of
the future so I would say first off you
want to sort of zero in on the people
who you can in fact influence some
people you're not going to make any
headway with for a variety of different
reasons so you want to you know this is
where I would say the interface between
philosophy and rhetoric is quite
important right right because oftentimes
philosophers make a case and they don't
attend to the audience that they are
communicating with and you do want to
pay attention to what will actually be
persuasive with this group of people or
this group of people or you know why and
and and I think it would take a lot of
discussions I was talking about this
with one of my clients yesterday a
psychotherapist who actually runs the
center and does training and I'm helping
him you know incorporate a lot of ethics
materials into the training for his
practicing psychotherapist and I was
saying nobody's ever convinced by a
philosophical argument just by itself I
mean maybe that does happen once in a
while I've never seen it I've never seen
anyone ever totally change their
position just because somebody made an
argument there has to be a lot of other
factors coming in that may look you know
kind of non rational or only semi
rational but but which play a part and
and a lot of good philosophers have
recognized this and a lot of good
philosophers have also not recognized
this in acted as if somehow just by
putting an idea or a set of ideas out
there they're gonna change people's
minds takes it takes more than that chip
when I taught in the prison were there
any trends and the philosophers issues
movements etc that my students there
were interested in it was pretty wide
gamut of stuff I was fortunate in that
they tended to be older than the typical
college students I did have a few like
you know 20 year olds but they were
mostly like 25 on up to like you know 60
or so and they they were intro
certain things that would be applicable
to the life that they were living in
there so you know stoicism was was
always a perennial favorite but they
were also very interested in social and
political philosophy very interested in
philosophy of religion I also taught
religious studies courses so there was a
good bit of overlap as I taught world
religions and religion in American
culture and the various scripture
classes and there was some interest in
epistemological issues but they they did
not have much patience for the sort of
typical you know analytic epistemology
that that people do these days because
they didn't see I mean they they saw
through it
they were very quite some of them were
quite interested in metaphysics and you
know I taught a huge range of classes I
mean I taught not just intro and ethics
and logic but the entire history of
philosophy sequence and special topics
business ethics social political
philosophy I think I taught about 11 or
12 different philosophy courses while I
was there
so yeah it's every another question
about relevance how relevant does Michel
Foucault these days in my opinion you
know it's sort of like with Heidegger
Foucault has some interesting ideas like
his distinction between exploitation
domination and subjective the subjective
ization I think is brilliant you know I
don't buy into his histories of
institutions or his history of sexuality
the ancient period I think quite often
Foucault tells a story that's partially
true and then partially sort of what
could be maybe this way you know kind of
conspiracy theory stuff but he does have
some interesting insights there are
quite a few people in sociology who use
him he made his way into other fields
besides philosophy I can tell you that
when it comes to like criminology
criminologist don't give a give a lot of
credence to discipline and punish
because it's it's a little bit too
restrictive and it's too easy
four people are trying to extrapolate
out about it but he's got he's got a lot
of really interesting ideas I like to
call quite a bit uh Nicholas writes
Camille Paglia is my favorite feminist
thinker yeah she's somebody I like I
haven't read any of her books for quite
a while but you know when when an op-ed
piece comes up I'll read her I can't
part of what I like about her is that
she she's not a party liner you know she
wants to say listen you're leaving this
out or you're leaving this out and and
it's usually something you know more is
something something important not just
for for that discourse but but the rest
that the rest of us can relate to I
wouldn't say that's important I don't
have an answer for name e07 scientific
realism or instrumental ism both of
those things mean so many different
things I have no idea what's what's
intended by them here those those are
just sort of jargon terms that that
people use to describe like entire
programs but there's more than one
scientific realism out there there's
more than one notion of instrumentalism
adam most of the contemporary thinkers
are marxist why i don't know that that's
the case at all that most of the
contemporary thinkers are Marxists you
know there's some that are Marxist and
then there's some that are like yeah
there's something to Marx but that
doesn't make you a Marxist I mean I'm a
Marxist if that's all it takes to to be
a Marxist you know but I'm not
any more than I am a you know
straight-out Aristotelian or just
party-line stoic or anything like that
so I think it here's here's a good
upshot it's important to not mistake
thinking that Marx has something
contribute with being a sort of
convinced I belong to the party
everything must be filtered through Marx
kind of Marxist all right
architect would you accept some
superhero comics post 80s Batman V for
Vendetta Swamp Thing anime and Japanese
some western videogames as good areas
for speculative fiction for the beginner
philosopher so that would be a question
that would be better addressed to
somebody who actually reads those those
sorts of things or plays video games or
watches anime regularly and I'm not any
of those my exposure to anime largely
comes through my son's interest in it
and so that's when he's here we'll watch
stuff together and then he'll correct me
about this plot line or this person and
and and I don't really you know I used
to read comic books when I was much
younger but I didn't read Batman and I
edit read v for vendetta or Swamp Thing
I mean I was into the x-men and I was
into Judge Dredd and Halo Jones and
things like that well everything that
came out through first - like the Badger
and and when I was there was another one
that was really good
but it's you know I gave away my comics
back in the 90s to some kid who really
liked them so I mean in theory could
that sort of thing be good for
speculative fiction I guess it probably
depends a lot on who's doing the writing
I will say one thing that you know I I
in my worlds of speculative fiction
series I focused on books and I focused
generally on series of books because I
want a coherent narrative universe but
we often end up talking about movies and
TV shows and there's a lot of great TV
stuff out there right now Westworld a
prime example exploring some really
interesting questions and not in a
heavy-handed way or not in a sloppy way
the how they're often done I'm looking
forward to seeing the
new man in the high castle out and yeah
there's the whole issue of whether how
far off book it is right I mean it's not
really that connected anymore to
silicate dicks novel which was actually
one of my favorite works by dick the man
in the high castle but it's pretty cool
what's what's being explored so I think
there's a lot of room out there for
exploring exploring speculative fiction
and the philosophical themes in it in in
a lot of different ways so I I don't
have but I don't have much stuff to say
about comic books unfortunately or anime
all right I've got a question from 3x4
architecture am i familiar with Nick
land
Joshua Gunn and Michael sorry Anne
they're all names that I've I've read
and I think I might
unless I'm no I'm mistaking him for
somebody else Nick land somebody else
had recommended him to me let me look up
real quick what is his story all
acceleration ISM I haven't really spent
much time looking into that sort of
stuff again you know who's got the the
time I would I would need some some time
you know set aside or do that says he's
connected with the dark enlightenment
when it comes to dark enlightenment
stuff I've mostly read mold bug and when
I read him I'm like well there's jock
morass again morass for those who don't
know was a neo reactionary thinker from
the early part of the 20th century
radicalized by the Dreyfus Affair helped
found accion Frost says so yeah it's I
know I'm afraid I don't have much much
to say any of those people but they
sound interesting I wish I had the time
to follow up on on all these things that
are interesting alright
Dubbs thoughts on essentialism in
general and in social sense essentialism
again one of those terms this is gonna
be my Serta standard response to jargon
terms what do you think about such and
such ISM what do you mean by it
if you mean two things have essences
I've got no problem with that we don't
have to say they all have essences in
the same way usually essentialism as
kind of a slur word that people use
you're being an essentialist because
you're saying people of you know this
type or all this way there's a better
way to say that you're being a dumb
prejudiced person and not actually
observing what's in front of your face
and making a priori judgments about
people you know so III don't know
there's the you know it depends on what
kind of essentialism we're talking about
here's another jargony one do you
believe Kant was more of a moral
constructivist rather than a moral
realist like Rawls did I mean so usually
moral realism is this notion that there
are like you know moral norms are
reflective of something that's actually
like out there in in the universe and
you can say somebody like like Hegel is
both a more realist and a moral
constructivist constructivist are saying
is it's basically something that we it's
through linguistic practices or culture
or whatever we construct those count as
a moral realist in that he thinks that
there you know there are some things
that are clearly identifiable through
the you know the rational the exercise
of the rational mind as moral norms that
are categorically binding now are they
out there in the world in the same way
that like natural laws are no they're
laws that freedom gives itself I mean
you can continue reinterpret conte in
whatever way you like sure you can do
that with anything Kerr you could turn
you know Aristotle into hardcore
conservative or into a you know super
progressive but then you're kind of
deforming things along the way aren't
you Dave I teach philosophy and play the
banjo to bluegrass style house you're
picking going I don't put in enough
practice quite frankly I don't play a
lot of classical banjo stuff I don't Lee
don't play bluegrass so I play some old
timey stuff but mostly it's playing rock
stuff of various sorts and you know
learning the the roles and and things
like that is just a means to an end I'm
more interested in playing UFO or
Motorhead or Judas Priest than I am in
other things all right Andrew can I
explain the schism between Deleuze
guitar ease work and Lacan I'm not too
familiar with either camps work but find
the guitar e Lacan relationship
fascinating humorous I don't know about
the relationship between guitar e &
Lacan personally I you know I work on
Lacan stuff I don't do much with the
loos and guitar E in part because well
there's two reasons one is you know I
don't know you'd only have so much time
and I you know I read the stuff back in
graduate school the other thing is I get
turned off by delusions who everything
is resumed attic and you know anything
can be anything quite frankly the stuff
by Deleuze that I like the best is where
he's not actually working with guitar
solely because his essays critical and
clinical you know and I think that's
what the English translation is but I
mean if we think about in this this way
right in a way it makes sense for the
losing guitar to think Lacan didn't go
far enough in reacting against a
psychoanalytic establishment I think one
of the things that's helpful is
background knowledge when you're reading
to lose in guitar E is to realize if
you're not in France that France is very
very different than say the United
States when it came to like psychiatric
care
United States we had a whole bunch of
different theories in play and different
people doing different things and in
France the psycho analyst ICO analysts
really dominated and they were not just
psycho analysts all getting along
together there was kind of a doctrine
here or way of doing things and losing
qatari are reacting against that in anti
Oedipus and people like Lacan who do
think that there's something to the
Oedipus conflicts although Lacan himself
relativize is it quite a bit saying you
know that it doesn't apply cross
culturally there's sort of collateral
damage I guess you could say uh ricki
yes what do I think of concept of Robert
a Heinlein moral philosophy you mean
like a a moral philosophy that would be
Heinlein Ian Heinlein went through
different phases you know you he
identified as a libertarian quite a bit
so I don't see why you would necessarily
need to have a Heinlein philosophy why
not just focus on libertarianism and use
things to illustrate it from his works I
mean a van Vogt would be another figure
in there like that a little bit earlier
all right Terra how would you compare
contrast edmund burke's reflections on
the revolution in France with the mice
it's interesting to see the conservative
and traditionalist response to the same
event yeah I'd have to spend time
reading it it's been a long time since
I've read Burke and demised I was only
really interested in because he fit into
this discussion about traditionalism
leading to axial Francaise and then also
figuring in with the Christian
philosophy debates because emil bhai a
brought him up as him and bottled and
others as an example of failed attempt
at christian philosophy so i don't i
don't have much to say about that here's
a very broad question from Vlada know
would you say philosophers live in a
dream world no not not generally i mean
there may be some philosophers who do
right
generally it helps to be independently
wealthy like have a trust fund or have a
really great academic position if you
want to live in a dream world because
for the rest of us you know there's the
reality principle of got a you know deal
with things you smack into a wall if you
would just keep walking there's nobody
there to clear it away for you and if
you if you think that you can do
whatever you like or say whatever you
like and you're not gonna face
repercussions for it then mmm that's not
that doesn't work out for most of us you
know most philosophers live in the same
same sort of general world as everybody
else
they just also do philosophy so yeah uh
let's see here muhammad who critiqued
Contin epistemology and how is that who
didn't critique of content epistemology
I mean you know the whole German
idealism is is essentially reacting to
cut right you've got Hegel and Schelling
and before the Fichte they're all
improving on can't Schopenhauer can't
get this right he got this wrong you
know you and you know people who are
totally against them like Jakob II you
know lots of people of critique Contin
and it's kept unco hang on so all right
nimi
do you watch counter contra points no
I'm not even sure what it is
Sacco do you think Spinoza was a stoic
and how he formulated his notion of
effects and book three of the ethics I
do not think Spinoza was a stoic I think
Spinoza is a spinosum I think he's doing
his own thing and I think that you can
say that there's similarities in some
respects to stone
on some things but you know ultimately
he's got his own project going you know
and he's working in a different sort of
medium - and the Stoics were here's a
flattering question from max how did I
get so handsome if indeed there is any
handsomeness that would probably be more
a matter of genetics than anything else
you know and you know I do personal
hygiene like didn't do that that would
probably be a problem Jermel if I had to
choose between the epicurean school and
see Rene X Cole which one seems closer
to the original definition of heinous
hedonism so there is no original
definition of hedonism hedonism is just
a term we use to talk about theories
that make pleasure the good but if I had
to choose between being an epicurean and
being a saranac I'd probably be a CRNA
ik you know if you're gonna just make
pleasure the the primary good you know
why try to sort of couch it in terms of
these mental pleasures and you know
freedom from pain and stuff like that
he'll go for pleasure try to arrange
your life in such a way that you're
gonna get as much of it as possible
oh wow
Jeff what are the most underrated
platonic dialogues in my opinion well
that is a good one
underrated platonic dialogues so I'm
gonna answer this in a very subjective
way I'll talk about the ones that I
really like that I don't see a lot of
people paying as much attention to
because you know I like a lot I really
like the Platonic dialogues in general
and everyone's a symposium so excellent
and it is excellent right and oh you got
to read the Republic and that's true you
do need to read the Republic I I think
the credo is one that's well worth
reading and often gets overlooked people
read it and they're just like I don't
know jump right to the argument about
the laws you know because
social contract theory and they skip
over all the other stuff at the
beginning that I think is really quite
cool
I love the gorgeous the gorgeous is a
very rich dialogue there's a lot going
on in the air I also really like the
protagonists that's that's there's a lot
of cool stuff I don't see a lot of
people referencing that as a matter of
fact you know I tend to like these ones
or he's facing off against some
interlocutor who can actually more or
less go toe-to-toe with them so those
are a few examples how do I take my
coffee with milk in it you know I'm a
good Wisconsin patriot in that in that
sense right supporting our local
industry I like my coffee very strong
but with with milk and that's that's
pretty much it
what are my thoughts on Julia Savola
people ask this almost every time I
don't have any I'd have to spend time
reading him here's look great what the
heck's what is your favorite barnyard
animal so we're putting aside like barn
cats because if you ask me what's my
favorite animal I'd say cat right but
you know we'll put aside barn cats
favorite barnyard animal I mean I can
tell you what it wouldn't be it
definitely wouldn't be a goat it
wouldn't be a pig what else we have I
mean I like horses but they're they're a
lot of maintenance
pretty dumb iron yard you know I mean I
don't like chickens so I couldn't say
those either and I can't say the farm
dog
I guess the cow you know I am bison are
kind of cool to see bison farms so all
right Adam has another one what are your
thoughts on the hard problem of
consciousness I don't really have
thoughts on that I'm not really bothered
by it and I don't I don't spend much
time worrying about
the problem of consciousness unless I
have to teach it you know the hard
problem of consciousness is how do you
get how do you get consciousness as
something that's distinctive out of you
know something that's that's not
consciousness right and there's so many
other people working on that it's not
something I worry about Wow
do you think Plato thought artists to be
useless or at least more useless than
not given his views on the superiority
of nature to art Plato himself was an
artist so there's a bit of irony in his
condemnation of memetic art because he
himself is writing philosophical
dialogues he thinks that art needs to
have a proper place and that we have to
have the right approach to it as a
matter of fact when you when you read
the Republic and if you only focus on
certain passages a bit like the poets
out of the city and look how he's saying
you know the the artist is is not as
good as the craftsman yes that's all
true but even the craftsman is not that
great because he's just copying the
ideal form so the artist would have to
be you know brought into the proper
perspective William Stephenson would I
be open to further discussing depression
anxiety in the future yeah very much so
as a matter of fact during like you know
mental health awareness week I was
planning on shooting a video on
depression and just didn't get to it
because I was too busy I wanted to do
like an update video about where I am
because I think the one I shot about
about depression was about five years
ago and you know I have long since gone
off of antidepressants and I'm generally
doing you know better although I have
some some days that are quite rough yeah
I'd definitely be doing more personal
videos later on oh yeah there's a baby
ducks yeah
I wouldn't pick geese geese are terrible
they're they're an awful kind of
creature you don't want to you know
they'll go after little children and
stuff Colin or am I gonna cover the
Poirot series in my fiction
I have no plans to cover Agatha Christie
if I was gonna do any mystery stuff I
would probably do Chesterton's father
Brown and Arthur Conan Doyle's Sherlock
Holmes stuff but yeah I I don't I don't
I don't plan on that I don't know I
suppose I could stick something like
that in there because I guess is
detective fiction speculative fiction
maybe in a way yeah
proof architect what is this passage
from Beyond Good and Evil mean the
falseness of a judgement is to us not
necessarily an objection to a judgement
it is here that our new language perhaps
sounds strangest yeah I mean for a lot
of people saying a judgement is false
that's the end of the story well we're
done with that one you know but it could
be that something is false but it's
still very interesting reviewing right
and you got to remember that for for
Nietzsche truth in in his theory of
about stuff truth there there's a couple
different meanings to truth in Nietzsche
and they need to be disentangled from
each other but you could say that truth
in a sense lies on a a basis of
falsification of agreement to count
certain falsehoods as as true so that's
that's not necessarily a reason to rule
it out
here's one from Rainey chief should one
seek justice when someone is wrong to
you even if doing so only causes more
problems is there a duty to fight for
what's right even if said on injustice
only targets oneself sometimes yes
sometimes no I mean it depends on what
the wrong is and what the actual you
know achievement is in imposing some
sort of justice I think you also be very
careful in not reading more justice into
your side than then
there actually is and and should you
seek justice when someone has wronged
you even if doing so only causes more
problems if it only causes more problems
then probably not you know but if
there's if there's other values at play
then perhaps it could be important
nimi 0-7 you need to watch counterpoints
it's not only philosophy it's an art
well I would have to have the time right
so people are always recommending things
to me if you want me to to have the time
to do that
that's what patreon is for right because
the more that I I have independent
support the less time I have to spend on
money-making projects to keep an income
going for my household my children you
know planning for retirement all that
sort of stuff it's just the way it works
right I don't I am not supported by a
university and I'm not supported by the
government louise asks have you read
Byung chul Han no I've never even heard
of him I wonder who that is it could be
interesting
Rory Dunnigan do you have any comments
on film or art in general as a
philosophical medium that's a good
question
yeah I do actually have some some
thoughts I think it's very tough to do
philosophy well in film or or in other
artistic genres and one reason for that
is there's there's a lot of ways in
which people do basically let's call it
cliche philosophy right they depict
somebody in a circumstance and what's
existentialism oh look how sad he is and
his life is kind of going to crap and
and he's having a crisis and well that's
already been done you know it's
difficult to do well I think a lot of
people think that they can just
study a little bit of philosophy and you
know grab a few ideas and then find some
way to represent it visually and it's
gonna automatically come across and
that's very rarely the case the other
thing that's important is when you're
doing philosophy well in like say
literature it's often happening through
the dialogue and dialogue writing is
itself a real skill that I don't think a
lot of people have mastered so yeah
awful philosophy what are my thoughts on
who throws em okay how is it done
concretely I can't quite wrap my head
around him but I find the thought
intriguing so the up okay is another way
of translating is bracketing right and
what you're doing is you're sort of
suspending your your natural what he
calls the natural attitude this is this
natural tendency to think that things
actually are the way that they're being
depicted and to withdraw not your
attention but your ascent from them and
just see how they're actually presenting
themselves to you
I think the epic a is one way of doing
phenomenology but I don't think you have
to you have to do it that way I mean
it's interesting if you read Merrill
Aponte's phenomenology of perception the
beginning of it he also talks about like
loosening the intentional threads he's
got a did some a different model then
who's role does Heidegger also talks
about like letting beings be letting the
phenomena present themselves to you mock
Schaller and other great phenomenologist
has another way of doing it
Gabrielle Marcel you know the key thing
is to actually allow things to present
themselves to you without allowing
yourself to start drawing all sorts of
inferences or making them be this way
and I think that was what what was going
on also with Baird sones attention to
the immediate data or Givens of
consciousness in the book that gets
translated as time and freewill but it
should be actually translated as the
immediate Givens of consciousness and I
think that's the same thing that Maurice
blown Dell is doing with his method of
imminence as well so I don't think you
have to do at Husserl's way
but a lot of people like to you know ash
what do I think of avarice and how it
compares to Thomism how Averroes system
I guess compares to Thomism again tome
ISM man whose tome ISM are you talking
about because you know we asked n Thomas
what Thomas says you're gonna ten
different answers because there's all
different schools of Thomism out there
you might say well I just mean you know
the school of st. Thomas himself well
that's hard to find because almost
everybody has some sort of
interpretation that they got from
whoever it is that they got introduced
to tome ISM from avarosa is an
interesting thinker for those who don't
know this is the avarosa that's Latin
version of even rushed he is one of the
later Islamic thinkers who used
Aristotle Thomas is reacting to him
obviously Thomas's is you know writing
in a different context he's got all
these other Christian thinkers and other
ancient thinkers who he's bringing into
the confluence in his works I don't
spend a lot of time reading Alvaro's
there are some people just down the
street because we have here you know in
what Milwaukee we have the Marquette
University Aquinas and the Arabs project
and so that's usually where I get to
hear the most about Ovid Orser or any of
the other Islamic thinkers so I don't
really have a way of comparing them now
here's a question how could I possibly
answer this the proof architect who's
better at using predicate logic
philosophers or mathematicians logicians
how would I know you know it's not I
think we have a logic games where like
you know timing you solve you know solve
these things using predicate logic I
think people use it as a tool because
that's all it is and it's like any other
thing if you use it a lot you get very
good at doing it if you only use it once
in a while then you're probably gonna be
kind of rusty sort of like using a
lawnmower yeah so Mike Garber
two certs good and evil superseded by
pragmatism it depends on whose
pragmatism you're talking about there's
a lot of pragmatism zout there I know a
William James wouldn't say that
neither would purse and I don't think
even John Dewey would so I'm not sure
what kind of pragmatism you have in mind
Jeff Sullivan I'd like to read some
philosophy of language off the top of
your head could you recommend a good
place to start
Plato's Cratylus I mean if you're gonna
do it in historical perspective that
probably is one of the places you should
start with and then read some Samaras
toddle you know he's got a lot of
remarks about about language in the
books that comprise what we call the
Organon I mean if you want more
contemporary stuff there's all sorts of
like readers out there I mean if you
want to jump into contemporary stuff
maybe get Umberto's echoes semi attics
in the theory of language good book
echoes good at explaining things to you
and introducing new stuff I will say one
thing about philosophy of language you
know Ferdinand de Saussure the great
linguist one of the founders of
structural linguistics said that in
order to understand language and be a
linguist you need to study multiple
languages and I think he's totally right
whenever I run into these people who say
that they've got a degree in linguistics
or they're studying linguistics and I'm
like great what languages are you
studying I only know English or a little
bit of Spanish you know I'm like well
that person's gonna be a waste of my
time
I'm not gonna bother even talking with
them because how do you get to learn
about language if you're not actually
studying different ways in which
language is articulated and works you
know it'd be sort of like saying yeah
you know I'm gonna be a mechanic
and you're like great what kind of cars
do you like to work on I only work on
Pontiacs
oh that's nice so you've only got that
frame of reference you know what the
hell are you gonna do when you work at
my Ford or you know let alone this Fiat
that keeps breaking down
how are you gonna make it make sense out
of that so you know I would say if you
want to do philosophy of language it's
really really helpful to have some
background again in studying languages
and studying them in a serious way we're
like you learn the actual grammar and
history of the language not just like
take a bunch of language tapes or
something like that so here's another
question by three by four architecture
have you read [ __ ] Colin responds no
I'm not even sure what that what that is
quite frankly some of these questions I
wish I had a better background proof
architect if you had enough support
would you consider be opening a more
formal first-order second-order logic
section to your YouTube channel so I
have a a other youtube channel smaller
one that I started a while back and
started loading up with videos and then
kind of petered out as I a lot you know
didn't have the time called critical
thinking logic and argumentation that's
where I would do that sort of thing and
I actually do have that built into my
patreon you know you have different
levels like when I hit this level of
support I'm going to do this thing when
I hit this level of support I'm going to
do this thing that's actually in there
if you go to the goals like it was up in
the left top left corner and you click
on those I'm gonna start building out
stuff in the critical thinking
argumentation logic channel if I if I
reach a high enough level of support
because then I'll have the time to do it
you know and yeah I definitely do stuff
on a first-order second-order logic I
mean I have plans to do all sorts of
things if I end up doing something with
that Channel all right
J to be to Nick what do I think of the
theory Plato's theology and philosophy
is heavily influenced by the Egyptians
I think it's bunk I think a lot of these
so-and-so was totally influenced by this
are usually bunk in general they rely on
so much could be should be maybe this
sort of logic and I've never you know
I've looked at some of these these
arguments and I've never found them
remotely convincing so six what to read
after cots well there's a lot of things
you could read after Conte
you could go backwards and read people
that you missed you could read you know
contemporaries of Conte you could read
some of the other German idealists you
could jump totally ahead to somebody
present-day konchem like say an or
one'll see what they make of him that
that could be interesting chip who are
some of the well-known writers who are
not usually thought of as philosophers
that you think are philosophically
interesting and significant that's a
good question
first person who comes to mind right off
the bat Rainer Maria Rilke I think this
is something I've meant to do work on
for a while and I just keep getting
sidetracked
Rilke has this really interesting
conception of what he what we translate
is solitude in German it's enzyme kite
and if there's in essence a metaphysics
of solitude worked out in his letters
and in sort of touched upon in his
poetry he actually does and there by the
way there's two different meanings to
solitude or ions on kite it can mean
being on your own and exploring this
sort of space within yourself and in
your relation to other things and it can
also mean loneliness and isolation he's
got two poems actually that touch on
different aspects of this one is called
itens M kite and it ends with two lovers
like facing away from each other as the
rain is coming down being lonely in the
same bed now that you know this is the
sort of stuff that that explains why
Rilke is an existentialist thinker
because these are really important
existentialist things we feel okay dick
has not thought of as a philosopher love
philip k dick he does a lot of great he
does more philosophy in his store
in interesting ways than many of my
contemporary peers do in all of their
their work I would say somebody else who
I really enjoy bore heyse you know write
short stories I'm not so big on his
poetry I like his short stories and
essays more really interesting stuff
going on in there
Dostoevsky of course lots of
philosophical discussion going on and
his works Iris Murdoch who also was a
philosopher okay yeah I mean we would
expect her novels to be to be kind of
filled with philosophy but those were
those are some of the people that I
really like all right normally I go
pretty far over but today I'm not gonna
be able to go too long in part because
I've got some other things I have to do
so I'll hang on for about maybe another
ten minutes or so and try to answer as
many questions as I can so six asks a
question that I don't really have a good
answer to what's the difference between
being becoming in-process I think that's
probably based in some sort of process
philosophy view being would be
understood as being very static and then
becoming is dynamic and processes the
process of becoming but you could look
at it in different other ways as well
you know oh here's a good question
Robert should we care what others think
of us whether people think we're wise or
foolish should we care if people think
we're wise it can easily become part of
our ego yeah I mean should we I guess I
would rephrase it and say should we care
what what everybody thinks of us or
should we which should we care about
every sort of thing people think about
us there are definitely some people that
who whose opinions should matter more
than others I mean this is something
actually discussed in the credo that
going back to that earlier question
about which platonic dialogues do you
think are kind of under
there's this wonderful discussion in
there between Socrates and credo about
whether we should care what the many
think or the wise and notice Socrates
doesn't say we shouldn't care about what
anybody thinks he says we should care
about what the people who actually know
what the hell they're talking about
think because if we think that something
is good and they tell us no it's bad
then we should probably take their views
into consideration so yeah I mean we
should care about what some people think
of us and we should think we should care
about why they think the way that they
do but should we be really invested in
what it's a public perception of us is
probably not you know I mean one of the
I'll tell you something personal when I
was a kid and this really went on into
my 20s but it was tapering off thank God
I had this feeling that that a lot of
other people do that like everything
that I was doing somebody was probably
paying attention to it and watching it
and so because people so easily
misunderstand or mistake what you're
doing I would sometimes like do things
deliberately to like show I was doing
this or show that that I thought things
this way and I spent so much time and
energy and that sort of [ __ ] that
nobody cares about it was so liberating
finding out that most people are not
paying attention most of the time you
don't really have to care what they
think about stuff because they're they
don't have any good basis what they're
saying right or thinking now of course
you do have to be prudent right if
you're going into a job interview and
you're like man I'm not gonna care what
anybody thinks of me I'm gonna wear
whatever the hell I want and put my feet
up on the desk smoke a cigarette you
know you're not gonna get the job unless
they're looking for somebody to do that
sort of thing or they're like wow this
guy's got some moxie
so obviously there are some cases where
you do have to care what people think
but there's there's there's ways of
doing that you know you go into the job
interview like totally nervous about
what this flunky across the desk thinks
of you it you know as a human being no
you care about what they think about you
as a candidate because that's all that
really matters so yeah oh wow
proof architect again what philosophy do
you need under your belt before you can
start tackling dorita's on grommet ology
well good question and we can broaden
this to think about other difficult
texts you might want to look at who is
being referenced right so right off the
bat
you know who do you notice is being
talked about jean-jacques rousseau you
need to you probably need to read a good
bit of Rousseau stuff or else the things
that area does there's Derrida is saying
about or so probably aren't going to
make so much sense claude lévi-strauss
would be a good one as well right Plato
you know you could go on and on and look
at well who is he actually referencing I
can tell you that for Derrida for early
Derrida phenomenology is very important
and there's a lineage that goes from
hood Cyril to Heidegger it's 11 oz those
are thinkers obviously some of the
thinkers that they're engaging with like
like Kant's you don't have to know
conscience I had an out to understand
Derrida but that sure can't hurt and
then he's very influenced by language
linguistic philosophy so you would want
to read to so sure you would claude
lévi-strauss fits into that that sort of
spectrum as well you know you probably
would want to read jakob s'en and
probably you want to go read purse as
well doing a different kind of semiotic
s-- and there's you know it's quite a
few other thinkers in there too that
would be would be good too couldn't hurt
to read some marks that that's always
kind of looming in the background for
Derrida I'd say
Hegel you don't need to read all of
Hegel
I mean you'd be screwed if you did right
all right let me see what's next Thomas
what's your relationship with Massimo
Pigliucci you like his book on stoicism
Massimo and I are colleagues and and
friends I would say we probably get a
chance to spend time in conversation a
few times a year in part cuz we're both
very busy but we always have great great
talks he's a great host and his book on
stoicism I mean you can read my route
not read you can watch my review of it I
thought it was pretty good
it's it's you know obviously there's a
lot of things that are left out but but
he's not trying to do everything and I
like the the dramatic what would you
call it the the technique of having it
be sort of a dialogue between him and
epictetus I thought that was pretty
smart on his part moscone was written a
lot of books so he's he's he's quite
good at that sort of thing but yeah
we're both members of the modern
stoicism team he and I get along very
well sometimes we shoot emails back and
forth about different ideas I would say
that you know when it comes to like how
did how to steer stoicism through the
shoals of politics and culture he's
probably more on the Left than I am I'm
pretty pretty much in the middle and
Parks I don't fit in well with left or
right he's marked more on the left but
you know he's a great interlocutor Adam
Teitur what makes a philosophical
concept mathematical theorem or physical
theory difficult to understand that's
these are still teaching but what makes
them difficult I think there could be a
lot of things that could make them
difficult some could be that they
presuppose a kind of terminology and
framework of thought like I I see this
happen a lot with Khan who I teach you
know pretty frequently I don't know how
many times have taught the
I work for the metaphysics of morals to
students who haven't had any philosophy
background and the key is to get them to
actually like crack the code and see
what the helis actually say and then
they're like oh yeah yeah I get that
you know another problem is when
philosophers don't provide enough
examples that can make it quite
difficult or they they pack the thing in
to too tight you know sometimes we need
like a little break in between you know
reading stuff that's why we're reading
Hegel could be so difficult what else
you know with can't I'll use that as an
example to she's got these great remarks
about happiness and the goal you know
the goal of ethics for Kant is duty it's
not happiness and he thinks that we're
not you know that we're not set up in
such a way that that following duty and
and rationality will actually make us
happy in the sense of satisfaction of
our desires and inclinations we do have
to postulate that things are that way
but but he doesn't really think things
are that way and students will be like
is he serious about this anybody like
yeah he's serious about this a man is he
serious about this that's kind of a
roadblock for a lot of students they're
like he can't possibly mean that and
that means they don't understand it so
to understand a position that's like
radically different from what you think
is quite quite tricky so all right let
me read down things scroll once I get
all these questions packed in here it
kind of gets out of control as far as
scrolling okay here is Akbar so that's
an Eastern Orthodoxy versus Roman
Catholicism well my personal view the
vs. is a mistake they're all part of one
big communion if they decide to be so
and I think a lot of the distinctions
between them turn out to be
misunderstandings of the other person's
position you know I see this a lot as a
as an an some scholar there there's a
lot of you know pretty crappy Eastern
Orthodox takes on and some who is you
know part of the Council of Bari where
the things were being debated between
Orthodox and Catholic thinkers in the
12th century but usually they just don't
understand what Anselm is saying and
often it's tendentious they haven't
actually read you know what he has to
say or they've only read it in order to
refute it and I think there's a lot of
that on the Catholic side and that
happens by the way within Catholicism
about other Catholic thinkers you know
so yeah in the early 20th century you
have all these people being condemned as
modernists including maurice Blondell
the guy i did my dissertation on who
definitely were not that it was other
Catholics who had a beef with them so I
think a lot of I think a lot of the vs.
there comes about because of the human
failings of the people involved in doing
that and I would you know I would go
further I would say you've got you know
you've got not just Roman Catholicism
because Catholicism is much broader than
just the Roman I mean I used to go to a
Maronite Rite Church myself there's a
number of different rights within within
the Catholicism and then you've got the
Eastern Orthodox family of churches and
then we've got all the other Eastern
Christians as well the Assyrian Church
of the east
you know the Ethiopian church the
Antiochian you know the Coptic Church
these all matter to the Malabar you know
Syria Christians they all have very rich
traditions to draw upon and interesting
thinkers I wish I had the time to
actually spend on them but I often don't
so alright let me see what else we got
here
the scrolling got a little bit screwed
up I'm not gonna be able to get to
everybody's questions it looks like so
I'm going to start jumping around a bit
I'll spend maybe another ten minutes or
so Wow
on this there we go
is it honest to call Aristotle uh
nominalist wouldn't the logical
conclusion of his moderate realism be
nominalism Aristotle is not a nominalist
not in the sense that that you know
akhom or you know early modern thinkers
are now medalists so you know they're
they're often reacting against Aristotle
rabba rabbit is it wrong to label
Kierkegaard as Protestant or Lutheran as
is so often lead unwell he has harshly
criticized them both no it's it's not
wrong to say that he was raised as a
Lutheran and it's not wrong to say that
he was a Protestant you know being a
Protestant basically means being
post-reformation 'el and not being part
of the earlier more apostolic churches
including Catholic Orthodox Eastern
Christian you know like we just
mentioned a moment ago and you know
there's a thing that we can call the
Protestant principle following Tillich
which is you know once you open the
doors to like everybody can criticize
everything well they do so Kierkegaard
is a critic of the Danish church of his
time but that doesn't mean that he's not
a Protestant Christian let's see Thomas
More you should get on the right show
with Robert right I'd like to see you
guys talk I don't know that show but I'm
always willing to go on and talk with
interlocutors from different stuff so if
you know how to make that happen you
know send an email and and that would be
kind of kind of interesting fizzer a
philosophic are there any interesting
Romanian philosophers okay le odd comes
to mind I think that that he's pretty
interesting
I've taught his stuff in in class before
scroll down a bit past some of these uh
[Music]
signor Pomodoro or am i interested in
philosophy of mathematics if so which
authors do you particularly enjoy
reading I used to be very interested in
it when I was a philosophy and
mathematics major in undergraduate and I
was mostly doing stuff in like you know
foundations of logic and thinking about
what what could in fact be represented
mathematically either well this is so I
thought you know what authors was I
reading at the time sort of a wide range
including people like John Stuart Mill
who thought you could make mathematics
empirical yeah all the way through to
you know like like Hofstadter and his
Goethe less your black book which we
spent a whole semester on by the way in
a seminar haven't done much with it for
a long time but my son Matthew
who's 11 is very interested in infinity
and in a few other issues and concepts
in the sphere of philosophy and
mathematics where they they coincide so
he and I actually do have some plans
this coming month in July when when he's
going to be visiting to do some research
together I'm gonna have him like reading
Kant or because he's talking he watches
like game theory and stuff like that I
don't know what if they do a good job or
not explaining this sort of stuff but
we're gonna do some videos on the
philosophy of mathematics together
he loves editing as well so so that'll
be a great research project for us
captain jhaza favorite Graham green
novel got into green through reading
philosophy my favorite one is the power
and the glory about the whiskey priest
in khat behind the lines in
revolutionary Mexico yeah yeah that is
definitely my absolute favorite green
although I really like green and there's
it's hard to find a bad green novel so
yeah um skip down a bit
I'm sorry for those that I'm not getting
too but we have swamp any questions here
uh oh here's a great question from David
is your wife a philosopher if so do you
think you could date someone who isn't
well I don't plan to date I have a wife
you know you're speaking hypothetically
of course like if if my wife wasn't in
the picture if I you know god forbid she
died and you know am I gonna like date
somebody who's not a philosopher and the
answer would be you know hypothetically
yes because being a philosopher is not
the absolutely deal-killer thing I think
you know I mean you can be a philosopher
and be a total jerk I know a lot of
colleagues like that people who I
wouldn't trust to walk down a dark alley
with love want to be involved in a
relationship with now is my wife a
philosopher yeah I would say she
actually is but you know it's not
because she's just studying philosophy
which she ant in fact is doing through
European graduate school she's working
on her dissertation writing on on Martin
Heidegger
but also because you know she's she's
doing the sort of stuff she's thinking
about the sort of things that
philosophers do how do things work you
know how do we move from the lower level
of generality to a higher level of
generality but you know I think you know
that that's a way of understanding
philosophy that's a bit more generic so
again somebody like Rainer Maria Rilke
the poet would be a philosopher
in that respect as well so yeah she yeah
she's definitely a philosopher and we
sometimes you know not as often as she
or I would like sometimes we get the
chance to go over philosophical texts
together and to discuss them and go into
detail it's probably something we need
to make more more time for together
Greg Sandler fan have you ever thought
about doing videos on theology and parts
of the Bible yeah I mean I could see
going at the Bible from sort of like a
comparative literature standpoint rather
than some sort of doctrinal standpoint I
think there's probably people out there
doing plenty of that already and you
know theology yeah I'd probably like
look at it like this is this person's
theology this is this person's theology
just present it the way I do but that
would you know I would have to have the
time for that and and I don't I don't
have that much time so all right let's
see what else we get oh here's a good
one from Lucas what do you think about
Bataille Bataille is that that that fun
crazy friend that you've got who will
take you out on a bender and you know
you wake up in the morning wondering
what the hell just happened
he's a cool thinker I like his work he's
not somebody I really have been able to
like do any writing on it neat point but
there's you know I mean there's so many
fingers I could say I haven't been able
to to write on at any any point as well
all right
mmm-hmm a lot of stuff about different
thinkers am i interested in them or
interested in those people here's a good
question from Vladimir my teacher tells
me what's true for me may not be true
for another person is he correct it
depends on the thing there are
definitely some sentences that trivially
are not true for you that are true for
me
I'll give you an example I'm Greg
Sandler it falls for you alright you're
not if you enunciate it your neck sailor
I I am now you could say well we have
you know you believe when we put this
this out there you could say I believe
that the statement I am Greg Sandler is
correct when when this guy over here
says it and that's true that's a way
around that there are there are gonna be
some things that are subjective and then
there are some other things where
somebody's right and somebody's wrong
and the key is to be able to figure out
okay which one is which you don't want
to go like all the way into moral
relativism or epistemological relativism
that's all relative anything could be up
for grabs because that's just incoherent
I mean that's not even worth well I mean
you could spend your time on it but I
think that's not really worth spending
your time on but we do have to recognize
a certain amount of relativity two
things don't we let's see here
I'm getting a little bit close to the
needing it to get the the other stuff
hmm Dane what do I think of Schopenhauer
should he be studied solely as an
influence of Nietzsche should his ideas
stand on their own
Schopenhauer is somebody who has been
getting more and more attention lately
and I mean in the last 20 years but he's
still I would say often like viewed
incorrectly as just like an adjunct to
Nietzsche he's worth reading and I enjoy
reading I think if you're going to do it
you should actually read you know for
full Gruder world as well as rat world
is will and representation rather than
just reading you know essays or things
like that so I think that that would be
quite quite good to spend time on do do
let's see what else can I quickly knock
out you know here's a good question
where was it was one about VidCon yeah
do I need to read the tracked hottest
before the philosophical investigations
couldn't hurt the track POTUS is a
pretty quick read fairly straightforward
kind of boring actually and much of the
middle stuff because he's really kind of
good just going over how logic works and
how how sentences would be
representational but I mean it's good to
know because in part you know he's
reacting against his former views so
yeah I think that could be that could be
good alright let me take one more
something I can
easily address if there is one like that
oh yeah I'll say this one from David
have I read Moses Maimonides yeah he's
you know he's within the sort of
Aristotelian tradition he's somebody who
is important for medieval philosophy
Maimonides is quite interesting and
unfortunately with this Aristotle in the
Aristotelian tradition conference coming
up at Marquette just down the road that
I'll be going to Monday through
Wednesday
there aren't going to be any papers on
Maimonides this time around but there
have been in the past some some pretty
good ones and and I enjoy reading him
but unfortunately he's one of those
people who I don't really have a lot of
time to read so you know like everything
else what are you what are you gonna do
you know alright so I am going to it's
125 here I have another thing I have to
host at 2:00 so I've gotta get on but
thanks for all of your questions and
comments if I didn't get to them I you
know sorry about that but it's there's
so many I can't always get to every
single one we'll be having another one
of these as usual next month so you can
go to my facebook page or I always post
it on patreon as well when these are
coming up other than that have a great
weekend and I will see you guys in some
other events